[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very huh do you wanna be friends
[Music]
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends do a dangerous quest
with all new faces
hello call me sage good move I made out
of sage and I am a sage so it works out
pretty well
I'm Patrick my name means toaster in
Celtic pretty sure it doesn't the most
amazing places look wouldn't worry about
us losing
[Music]
starts with an L weird sponge on the run
I love your sense of irony Patrick thank
you I love my sense of irony to jungle
this is a whole new thing nobody told us
we add it to a whole new thing
[Music]
I'm coming grandpa
morning did you guys see Spencer this is
that think he went back in we gotta go
get it are we in Florida oh my god wait
my joints feel like bought us myself I
came back and things actually got worse
look at this
whoa - do you have some cashews in the
game it busted listen up now this is a
dangerous place you've got to have eyes
in the back
Sam he'll just happen to him
hell is this
would you look at me I haven't looked
like this since never
you look like this never I think my eyes
are a different color all of you is a
different color strengths and weaknesses
linguistics oh goodness nunchucks that's
new
damn that's a good list weaknesses heat
Sun and stain how is this guy a
character in an adventure game Spencer
and Bethany
this next adventure is even more
challenging
this time not all of you will leave the
gang
[Music]
let me touch mine you smell where is
Bethany it's right here she says oh my
god like I'm a total horse Hey terrible
job what are you talking about passed my
driver's test last month that's good
we're not gonna make it we're gonna make
it hopefully we're gonna make it we're
gonna make it
we're not gonna make it
[Music]
what happened yes I'm back I missed you
so much oh my god you guys hi Bethenny
you guys back in Jumanji I'm Sonic a
little ball of super energy in an
extremely handsome package on my planet
people were always after my powers so I
came to yours it gets a little lonely I
can't with that guy why are you hiding
out in my garage my power to conquer the
universe you have to help me no no
please it's life or death good morning
my royal chum mr. dr. Robotnik I'm going
to give you five seconds to tell me
where it is wait
Road Trip this can't be happening to me
oh my god stop back alright what the
world's largest rubber band ball we
gotta see it no this is not some fun
family road trip you're right it was
lame gift shop was cool though whatever
this creature is I'm going to uncover
the source its power
[Music]
I just thought you might like the latte
with steamed Austrian goat milk of
course I would a lot to take I love the
way you make them we gotta lay low let
me show you how it's done
so super get out of here yeah time to go
that was an illegal left by the way why
would you throw your life away for this
silly little alien your time is my
friend
[Applause]
to protect my friends
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal there is an
elevator in the elevator you press the
button to the floor with no name behind
those doors is a life you always tremor
[Music]
but here this weekend
you will be our campus
here anything and everything is possible
no service it's not everything is
possible
good evening I am mr. Erick let me
officially welcome you to Fantasy Island
[Applause]
curious how this all works what if your
fantasy involves a person from your life
Holograms like to buck what if it's
somebody who died to possum so what's
your fantasy revenge on a childhood
bully at the your life is about to
change
[Music]
that is really good hologram there is
only one fantasy per guess and you must
see your fantasy through no matter what
oh my god that's really hurt
[Music]
this is not what I meant what the hell
is this place
people died here the islands twisting
what we ask
weren't brought here to have our own
fantasies we were brought here to be a
part of something else I'm your friend
oh it's about to start
ready ready popcorn nachos she prepared
with red licorice all right it's time we
made a new movie good idea Scoob but
first we need a trailer Oh
can you do the trailers eye voice mm let
me give it a shot
in the world destroyed by evil discover
the ethnic origin story the greatest
team of heroes
didn't his face
of mystery nailed it
[Music]
hi this mangy stray is coming with me
strength
okay then what's his name his name's are
you Scooby middle name doobie last name
do would always be without you I feel
awesome I love it
never take it off
maybe don't do that again I'm Fred this
is Velma hi
that's Daphne hey I'm Shaggy and this is
scooby-doo nice to meet you
I
[Music]
hello
whoa whoa whoa Shaggy and Scooby were
taken do you realize where we are look a
real man the clean modernist they the
cool blue color palette
we're in Mikey did you say I can't nope
I said Falconeri just like you maybe
this can lead us to Scooby and Shaggy
trace amounts of mustache oil
twelve-year-old scotch
it's the bad guy my dad
[Music]
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car might we
got more time behind us than in front
please I'm gonna be running down
criminals till I'm 100 not me on guitar
this time we be good men
[ __ ] wants to sing that song might put
you on a new team you're working with
ammo now okay ammo is a high school
musical boy band with guns look great
grandpa so you're that guy there's
always one right up till there's not
that's what I like teamwork
[Music]
Marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you I don't trust a person
that don't want to kill he'll put my
name up thanks a lot we got it Marcus we
appreciate it
but family is the only thing that
matters so I'm not letting you go on a
suicide mission alone one last time one
last time
Oh
[Music]
getting all these helicopters
oh this is my wife's car cover the front
door she knows she always knows hello
it's Peter Spencer I'm here about
selling the house anyone home
[Music]
is it detective Muldoon
this is Peter Spencer something happened
to me a 44 Raber drive someone was
murdered at that house why did you never
go into that place something never felt
right about it looks like we got another
one
do you think that the body any sounds
related I went to the house I see
something followed me home
[Music]
which might we need to leave right now
[Applause]
long ago the world was full of wonder it
was adventurous there was magic
but it wasn't easy to master so the
world found a simpler way to get by but
I hope there's a little magic left in
you there dad said to give you this when
you were both over 16
it's a wizard step dad was a wizard your
dad was an accountant
this spell brings him back what back
like back to life that's not possible it
is with this I'm gonna meet dad
Oh feet
dad we have 24 hours to bring the rest
of them back we're going on a quits
but uh
I think we should take the path the
barrel but these first ladies faster no
the long run fine dad gotta go
[Music]
there could be booby traps
before you cast a spell again you're
gonna have to practice
elbows out beep apart backs like the
house
oh yeah what we need spell that creates
a magical bridge you can walk on if you
believe the bridge is there then it's
there you can do this
[Music]
[Applause]
let the beat drop I was the world's
greatest spy sleepy night night but then
you turning into a pigeon you've got to
unburden right now
you kind of bird it yourself oh there's
a bad guy who needs to be stopped and
now I have to try to stop him while
being a bird okay Wow
[Music]
let's get weird boom
[Music]
all right come where I study it's about
to get messy time to go sleepy
night-night
I miss my hands what would you want to
be known for on earth we only have a
short time on this planet
you want to become the person that you
were born to be don't waste your time on
all the junk of life
chewy
spend your precious hours doing what
will bring out the real you
the brilliant passionate youth
that's ready to contribute something
meaningful into this world
I got the gig I really need a haircut
today man can you fit man Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so what do you want to be before
probably for doing this funny cowboy
dance
[Music]
[Applause]
the Yukon is a dangerous place you never
know what's coming I came up here
because I didn't want to be around
anyone and then I met buck he was a dog
like no other even spoiled
[Music]
and each suffered
[Music]
but he could not be broken
I don't know where you came from but I
know where you are now welcome to the
last place on the earth I should let him
have a minute it doesn't look like he's
ever seen snow before how do you feel
about an adventure
beyond old maps we should go you and I
or no one's ever been before
[Music]
see what's out there
[Music]
glad you're enjoying this
I never saw him believe in anything as
much as he believes in you
[Music]
what do you say buck
adventure of a lifetime
you must sleep in for two days in my bed
what's going on with you what's new how
much
[Music]
I hate the idea of you down there by
yourself all the time just drink it I
appreciate it
but it's I'm fine ever since I've heard
how weird and I suppose you're wondering
why I called you over here I didn't need
to go where
our basketball coach had a heart attack
the other night they need a new coach
Jack then you know you give see many
good know the last time they made the
playoffs back when you were playing your
Marcus right that's right how many three
two markets make last year a percentage
of 26 yeah wonder why they're leaving
you open it's because they don't think
you could hit the ocean from the beach
backside show as bread
[Music]
so I like coaching so far great getting
used to the players or players
[Music]
I heard you're coaching basketball yeah
keeps me busy keeps my mind off other
things to him what you said
external audits and i market myself
carry other name I have my regrets
[Music]
games online I want you taking a shot
why is that so hard for you believe what
I hear the best player on team
[Music]
really her suffering I just want you to
be happy again but you gotta want it too
keep pressing traffic taking charges
you guys own this tonight so
in the end
[Music]
[Music]